your real job your day job is education
how does that change coming out of all
this oh so the question is what's going
on with colleges I have been on a bit of
a crusade to say we should be graduating
half as many people from colleges we are
currently graduating there are majors
that should be minors they're minors it
should be courses and their courses that
should be history
noticed upon there you cannot pay a
quarter of a million dollars in major in
sociology I just
if this podcast gets to our sociology
chair there's gonna be a [ __ ] session I
don't care you cannot it is a non
extinguish herbal debt a quarter of a
million dollars to major in sociology
and so and and at the same time the cost
of college is just soaring or maybe not
going forward and the question is why
what I can tell you is my department is
chemistry runs leaner and meaner than
when I got here less staff per capita
less support for capita and we're pretty
close to the top and so I got a figure
that's general so the question is where
is all the money going and I think it's
a lot of unfunded mandates so when
you're accepting federal dollars you
have to do all sorts of stuff which
includes having Dean's of diversity
who's having accounting things and all
sorts of you know all sorts of stuff so
colleges are just so much more
complicated than they used to be and
meanwhile you know the cost of dorms and
suffer going up because the kids there's
a there's a an arms race going on so if
if one schools building fancy dorms as
for all the freshmen are gonna go
there's an arms race that's gonna appear
in medical school soon and why you just
just declared free tuition no tuition
for all med students from here on out
last year no tuition now imagine you're
sitting at Columbia's our first-year med
student and often the headline says NYU
has note
tuition as of the stain you're going I
turned down NYU I can't believe I turn
down and right so what's the best med
school in the country right now and
where you because it's the only place
you go free and so that's gonna keep
happening then what's gonna happen to
that well what's gonna happen to that
then society's gonna say okay now that
you're not paying a fortune you get to
work cheaper now you get we get to send
you places we get to send you to you
know Sheboygan where we need more
doctors somehow this could be the
beginning of a more social is a
socialized medical care curiously enough
so I don't know I don't know where
academia is going but we're we're way
too expensive you should not be studying
English literature with a 500 English
SAT and they're out there my son went to
a four-year college to a two-year
college and the Adirondacks that offered
four majors they were all very pragmatic
was a great program he went to a
four-year college after that to get it
finished a four-year degree not a famous
place but uh he'd studied event
management now he works for the CFR so
so I think college must be much more
pragmatic an the problem with that is is
there's a lot of majors and stuff out
there that aren't pragmatic you think
that the way the education is delivered
changes right that this is kind of
technically speaking well just there's a
lot of kids sitting at home right now
saying you know hey I'm calling into my
Cornell class and I'm paying all this
money one should I even be in college if
if I'm not going in person and then two
is you know does the cost change if the
experience changes to some degree well
the experience definitely changes right
now we've got a problem with things like
lab courses or a farce
right we pretend to teach and they
pretend to learn that's it
we're laboring up for what to do lab
courses if we can't open up I just don't
think you can keep playing the game that
a lab course doesn't require going in
the lab we made the emphasize laboratory
right
who says
freshman chemists have to go in the lab
right he could just learn chemistry at
the labs I remember thinking pretty
badly anyway so you know who cares I'm
not sure a big loss there I do think
there's a real social upheaval when
people finally figure out that you can
do something online and then the
question is what is the role of elite
I'm told Harvard Law School now it takes
about four hours to do the work if
someone's from Harvard Law School
disagrees send me an email I don't care
I'm glad to hear it but I had a student
who went there he said he takes about
four hours to do the work that's not the
paper chase which was a famous movie
book years ago where it was just
cutthroat and killer now now it's it
seems like a finishing school if that's
true if that's true so you know business
schools are really about just getting
the sheepskin and being able to say you
have an MBA that seems so wasteful I
don't think you should have to take what
is it seven years to get a law degree
this Frank Abagnale II who was the the
famous imposter he passed the bar
without going to college I think a
four-year degree that includes a major
in law that then you take the bar would
be fine there's a but that meant law
schools right now our cash cows right
that that's where the business school is
a cash cow you know medical schools are
cash cows because they have because they
have clinical treatment facilities so
they're hospitals and med schools that's
gliese being ethical but we didn't have
the bodies to work with so you to run a
med school you have to have a lot of
indigent people the thing that I think
is really interesting is there's two
things at play right so one is this
Kovac thing kind of exposed a lot of
shams in society one of them immediately
becomes hey do I have to go in the
classroom or kind of swatch online if I
could watch online how does that change
my expectation I do think there's a lot
of value to the social experience right
which I think you know some people still
for sure desire and seek out
but the other piece of it is the
business of the school right and so you
know one of the things I've said it's
like look a lot of these schools they've
got massive asset management firms right
I mean look these endowments are
billions and billions of dollars and
part of what I think people are asking
is just does any of that change right
does the way that they allocate capital
change is the way they invest change
does the way that the federal government
interacts with the schools who have
large endowments change like like what
is the impact to the actual business of
the school and I don't think people know
yet right like I know here's the problem
though and that is if you can find a way
that that huge wealth is distorting the
system then you have a case but for
example I'm sitting in a building called
Olin Hall created by the Olin family
which Olin Chemical next doors Baker lab
which is George Fisher Baker who was a
JPMorgan pier to the extent they exist
across the hall across the street is a
building built by Seth Klarman next door
is a building built by john d
rockefeller Bill Gates is down the
street Duffield of PeopleSoft is at the
end of the road you know it just they're
everywhere these are all buildings that
were built with money that was not
tuition money now some of the money
actually is tuition money because yeah
often don't get the full donation thank
you shockingly small amounts though but
um but in any case every dollar that one
of those rich bastards gives us like
cysts Sandy Weill gave us wile all his
money that he doesn't have to pay for
and the state doesn't have to pay from
the taxpayers don't have to pay for us
so it's like you know the Hughes
foundation so the question is is is that
efficient are we squandering money
because that it's possible but you know
you know if you look at a school like
MIT right now they're doing amazing
things stampers doing some amazing
things we're seeing amazing things
different areas and and so it's not
obvious to me that the
big endowments are to be criticized
because Harvard for example you get so
much aid to go there Harbor and I heard
rumor said they were gonna shut down in
the fall because the amount of money
costs to teach the undergrads from their
cash flow it's cheaper for them not to
teach others and and so so it's a
subsidy for them and and so I think you
know we could get rid of a lot of
colleges replace them with tech schools
various you know that the guy who was
fixing the elevator a year ago I was
talkin to and he was still an apprentice
but he said after five years he gets
real pay said how much he said over a
hundred I should you become an elevator
repair guy or major in sociology right
that's the question I think a lot of
people the argument of hey there's a big
separation at the higher education level
of like the elite schools have a very
material serious impact and kind of the
economics there make sense and you can
measure what goes in and what comes out
but there's just too many schools Rose
is a whole nother level school can't
develop an endowment one could make the
argument that that they're pointing out
students who are not extinguishing the
cost of the school right if the school's
product is as educated people if if
they're impoverished you know is it was
it really worth it I know there's
humanists we're gonna go but you have to
a few minutes well Harvard has
humanities Cornell has humanities they
are a it's some level kind of a social
program that you can afford to have if
you were a financially powerful school
right in the olden days schools just
weren't expensive and so you could
actually and and by the way someone who
came to Cornell a hundred years ago a
major to philosophy so like that they
came from wealthy families they came
from families where you can afford to do
that and so
it's a very complicated mathematics to
understand colleges but I do
we're not wallowing in money people
think the endowment harvard i sat with
the the the the assistant provost of
harvard in the middle of the financial
crisis sitting in my office and he
really got pretty honest with me there
and he says he says we don't know how
we're gonna make payroll and I know
Cornell had that problem and what it is
what people don't understand about the
endowments is it's not a big Harvard
centavos not a big 40 billion pot of
money it's not a 40 billion pile of of
equities it's just exceedingly complex
cordon off piles of things some of which
are illiquid assets they might be they
might own Timberland in Siberia right
guys you can't just liquidate that stuff
but a lot of its like for example my
salaries paid by the endowment and so
they can't just take the money that they
would have paid me so I defer the cost
of me and and and and there's all sorts
of activities on campus that are paid by
the endowment you know that the lacrosse
coach is an endowed coach you know
things like that and in and that pays
for that all pays for things that we
either could not afford or or or would
have to use tuition dollars together